[Music]
welcome to my ultimate cookery course
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stake your life on
right now it's all about making it easy
[Music]
making it easy for yourself in the
kitchen means using the time you have
effectively and the one thing that can
really help you do that is your freezer
[Music]
my recipe for meatballs is so versatile
it can be used to make a dozen amazing
dishes
one of my favorites is meatballs in
fragrant coconut broth
having a freezer of home-cooked
delicious food ready to go can be a real
life saver it means you never have to
compromise on flavor these meatballs are
delicious but more importantly they
freeze so well
first off get your pan on and start
sweating off your onions and your garlic
this recipe involves making the
meatballs in a classic way but the
exciting part
is actually cook them in coconut milk
and it gives a really nice new dimension
to a sort of soft
rich sumptuous meatball
chop the onion nice and finely keeping
those slices very close together close
closer the slices the finer the onions
pat it back down at an angle slice down
and just chop
i want the onions nice and fine because
i want some finesse to these meatballs
and the secret of a really good meatball
is the texture
getting that balance right
between the minced beef the breadcrumbs
the milk
and the seasoning a couple cloves of
garlic slice the garlic really nice and
thinly
nice pan nice and hot a tablespoon of
olive oil quite generous with the olive
oil
onions and garlic in a touch of salt
and pepper
with your mince open it up a little bit
and sort of pat it out
salt
and pepper
for me
a good meatball is all about the
softness the texture of that rich beef
and the way it sort of melts in your
mouth you can color it on the outside
but you want it nice and soft and sort
of rich in the center mix that in
beautifully
and then paste it back out again i've
got some really nice
dried chili flakes i'm gonna season the
onions with the chili flakes chili
flakes in
cook that out for two minutes
i'm gonna add some milk
[Music]
take your bread crumbs make a little
well three four tablespoons of milk that
makes a sort of nice
slightly doughy texture
but it lightens the texture of the
meatball
place that
in
add your onions your garlic and your
chilli in there as well
nice put your hands in there and start
mixing them
if you've got the right amount of milk
and breadcrumbs it doesn't mean binding
with an egg
don't make them too small
the problem with making them too small
is the fact that they dry out quickly
just the size of a golf ball
a little bit bigger
nice
really nice tight squeeze
that stops it from breaking up
it always pays to double the recipe and
spend a bit more time making extra
meatballs so you can freeze a batch
ready for another time
give the pan a little wipe out
don't wash out that pan we've got that
flavour from the onions and the garlic
at the bottom get that pan nice and hot
a touch of olive oil in there
place them
at the top of your pan
nice and gently
sit them in the oil
get a pallet knife and go underneath
them and just sort of
tilt the pan and let the pan cook the
back of the meatball we're going to add
some heat coanda seeds
slightly spicy and peppery just to give
a really nice flavor to the coconut milk
in
next some cardamom seeds three or four
onto the board knife on
in a little touch of turmeric into the
center of the pan that's going to give
it a really nice spicy flavor
a little pinch
cinnamon
all the time you're doing this those
meatballs are just getting tastier and
tastier
a couple of dried chilies let them
infuse in that oil
and then some lemongrass just take the
back of your knife and sort of
beat it down that starts to release all
that lovely sort of fragrance like
someone's just
let off the most amazing
fragrant air freshener in the lemongrass
and finally some fresh ginger
just peel
and slice nice and
thinly time now
to turn them over
and let the other half a wonderful
flavor
chicken stock
in
bring the stock up to the boil turn the
gas up and then add the coconut milk
i want the coconut milk just sitting
underneath the top of the meatball
coconut milk in
and that sort of
gives it that creamy richness but it's
not heavy it's a fragrant
light richness
before we start simmering check the
seasoning
that nice soft texture of the meatball
but that fragrance light richness of the
coconut broth just gonna cook those
meatballs perfectly
bring the broth up to the boil then
simmer gently for eight to ten minutes
touch them with your finger this should
be slightly pliable but
slightly springy gas off i'm gonna
finish it off with something light and
fresh zest of lime but i want the zest
on top of the meatball
so i'll cut through that richness
and then finally
squeeze the fresh
lime and that just gives it that nice
zesty amazing taste
stir in the juice
[Music]
i've got that kick and that
vibrant taste
the exciting part
when you come to serve it
be generous with that coconut broth
tilt the pan
get a good couple of ladles of the broth
in
meatballs
[Music]
and that is a very
delicious way of eating a old-fashioned
meatball
and bringing it into the 21st century
and they're just as good cooked from
frozen as well
[Music]
the secret to stress-free cooking is
making it easy for yourself
here are three more recipes all based on
my delicious freezer friendly meatballs
just defrost them before you get started
first up beef meatballs with ariketti
kale and pine nuts
[Music]
add meatballs to hot oil
and brown
meanwhile cook educated pasta
then add chopped garlic to the meatballs
and shredded kale a delicious green veg
packed with vitamins which cooks in
minutes
cabbage is a great alternative if you
can't get kale
put in some of the cooking water from
the pasta to steam
when the pasta is cooked al dente drain
and add to the meatballs
season
then finish with sweet buttery pine nuts
and grated fresh parmesan cheese
meatballs with oliketti kale and pine
nuts from meatballs to meal in minutes
my next easy standby supper is beef
meatball sandwich with melting
mozzarella and tomato salsa
[Music]
top a lightly toasted roll with
pan-fried meatballs then tear off chunks
of creamy buffalo mozzarella pile it on
and melt it under the grill
for the tangy salsa slice sweet red
onion then add juicy diced tomatoes and
roughly chop fresh coriander
season and drizzle with olive oil
spoon over
[Music]
perfect in a flash beef meatball
sandwich with melting mozzarella and a
tomato salsa a sandwich to die for
my final super easy meatball recipe is
fiery meatball soup
[Music]
fried chopped onion and finely sliced
garlic in hot olive oil
add cumin seeds for warmth
and add your meatballs
cook on a high heat to get all those
aromatic flavors out
once the meatballs are browned add hot
chili paste for a spicy kick
tinned tomatoes
dried oregano and a litre of beef stock
[Music]
then simmer
[Music]
next add sweet corn
and chop courgettes
[Music]
to finish add hot jalapeno peppers
chopped fresh coriander and crushed
tortilla chips
a one-pot meatball wonder that really
packs a punch fiery meatball soup
[Music]
one versatile meatball recipe four
deliciously different dishes food that's
certain to make your life in the kitchen
easier and stress-free
amazing
whether you're making great food to
freeze or to take straight to the table
you need to know how to shop for the
best ingredients
next up my shopping guide to oils
it doesn't matter if you're baking
frying or dressing salads using the
right oil can dramatically alter the
taste and texture
here are the most common oils and what
to use them for
[Music]
sunflower oil is a good value
all-rounder nice and light for frying
baking in dressings and spicy dishes
groundnuts or peanut oil is great for
cooking on high heat as it gets really
hot without burning
sesame oil a flavoursome sweet and nutty
oil perfect sprinkled over asian dishes
before serving
rapeseed oil is a healthier choice for
using in salads
i love walnut oil fantastically fragrant
it's brilliant for salad dressings and
it gives cakes a distinctive flavor
but the oil i use most in my cooking is
olive oil
[Music]
to find some of the best olive oils sold
in britain you have to go to one of the
most unlikely places
an electrical shop in london's east end
[Music]
turkish born mehmet morat has olive all
in his blood
my family's produced this olive oil for
centuries what he doesn't know about it
isn't worth knowing
the very best extra virgin olive oil is
first cold pressed it's actually pressed
by stone and then it's put through a
centrifugal spinner which spins out all
the bitter waters
and then you've got pure olive oil cold
pressed olive oil and you've got to
taste it to believe it
pour a little sample
slurp it draw it in without don't
swallow it warm it in your mouth coat
the whole of the inside of your mouth
with it and then swallow
it'll go down like fruit juice and it
will leave no greasiness or oiliness in
your mouth whatsoever
absolutely sensational beautiful
my favorite use of any olive oils is to
pour it into a bowl room temperature rub
some wild oregano into it and get some
fresh crusty bread and just dip it it's
food on its own don't need anything else
welcome back to my ultimate cookery
course next on my guide to making it
easy i'll be creating a sweet treat to
drool over
i want the chocolate my little
matchsticks dotted around
but first
my quick guide to the basic kit you need
to get cooking fantastic food
you don't need to spend a fortune on
masses of kitchen equipment
here are three more kitchen essentials
[Music]
whisk spoon and spatula
these three items are so cheap yet they
are so important to great home cooking
a whisk
there's so much more control when you've
got something whisking in your hand you
can gauge it so much better than you can
if it's an electric mixer
the bigger the balloon on your hand
whisk the faster it'll whip as it draws
in more air wooden spoons don't scratch
pans and should be washed by hand
spatulas are indispensable for baking or
mixing
make sure it's heat resistant so it
doesn't melt
but more importantly phenomenal for
making omelettes great with scrambled
eggs and you waste nothing because the
spatula almost cleans the bowl
instantly
with these three you'll be well on your
way to cooking like a pro
and you'll need all three for my next
recipe
[Music]
my take on classic chocolate brownies is
guaranteed but a smart on anyone's face
and not just when they're fresh out of
the oven
blondies
stock up in these delicious blondies
they'll keep for up to a week and it's a
great way of getting ahead of your
expecting guest round
first off melt the butter for the
mixture
we've had hundreds and hundreds of
brownies the sort of white chocolate
version i.e blondies are amazing a
little bit more subtle keep a little
knob of butter
for the end just to grease your baking
tray turn the gas down
and gently melt that butter
caster sugar into the bowl
[Music]
just give that butter a little whisk
sort of makes the mixture a little bit
lighter slightly fluffy
off with the gas
a pinch of salt in the sugar then make a
little well in the middle
and sort of whisk
you can see
it's already gone nice and blonde
love it
give that
a really good mix
and the secret with the butter be
slightly warm sort of it melts the sugar
nice and smooth
lovely
a teaspoon of
vanilla extract in
next lightly whisk in two whole eggs
just give them a little beat
this is such
a delicious recipe yet so simple whisk
in the eggs looking for that nice sort
of rich textured
smooth paste
you can see why we call these
blondies beautiful
next teaspoon of baking powder baking
powder in
then half a teaspoon of baking soda
that aerates the mixture and gives it
that little tartness you'll see this
sort of
rise instantly the minute they hit the
oven
and then
your flour whisk with one hand
and just
slowly
add half the flour first
get that all mixed up make sure that
mixture is really nice
and smooth
check it
occasionally
no lumps half flour in
and then the other half in
you'll feel it sort of almost
nice and firm
and that's why
it's so important to add the flour in
stages it stops the mixture going
lumpy it should be just dropping off the
whisk
beautiful
change over from a whisk to a spoon
next i want some texture some nice sweet
chewiness to the blondies
dried cranberries they bake beautifully
but it gives the blondie a really nice
sort of chewy sweetness
in the center next
a white chocolate
i'm not gonna grate it i'm gonna chop it
up just slice it
like little bits of shrapnel
i want the chocolate like little
matchsticks dotted around
now chocolate in
lovely
fold that in i want a nice even
distribution of those wonderful dried
cranberries
don't over mix it i want to break up
that chocolate
nice even mix of cranberries and
chocolate
you can see the chocolate there'll be
parts of the chocolate in the oven that
will actually melt
there'll be like little pools of white
melted chocolate in the center
now
a baking tray
small little knob of butter
and the grease baking tray and line it
some greaseproof paper and just
over extend it
shiny side out dull side hits the bottom
of the tray in
greaseproof
allows me to maximize on the white
chocolate inside the mix no greaseproof
paper the chocolate can melt and almost
stick to the tray so the paper is just a
really nice insurance policy secondly we
want that rise and that sort of
crispness now with the mix get your
spatula all the way around i don't want
to see anything left in that bowl
position the bowl over your tray
nice and carefully
loudly
don't leave that slice in the bowl
nobody's licking that one
and then just take the back of the
spatula go into the corners push and
come back into the middle
turn the tray around let it work to your
advantage
try and get it evenly positioned in the
tray
if it goes in even
it cooks evenly
make sure you smooth out the top of the
blondie with the back of the spatula
and then into the oven it's going to
rise
nice and crisp
all that soft gooeyness in the center
bake your blondies at 180 degrees for 35
to 40 minutes
that
smells incredible
it's got that crisp edge on the outside
in that sort of soft gooey center
leave that to cool down and it's going
to sort of firm up and wrinkle but it'll
stay nice and gooey in the center once
it's cooled down take it out and start
slicing
[Music]
mouth-watering blonde is a fantastic
easy treat to have on hand for yourself
or to share
[Music]
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips
to make your life easier make sure you
make the most of your freezer my tip for
amazing tuna capacio is to freeze it
first and it will slice beautifully
it's wise to save leftover wine for
cooking my tip is to freeze the
remaining wine in freezer bags or ice
cube trays it's great in stocks and
sauces
[Music]
when you freeze suits or stews in tubs
the tip is not to overfill them leave
room to expand in the container
a great tip for a cheap homemade ice
cream buy a high quality vanilla ice
cream and make it your own by mixing in
berries chocolate or my favorite rum and
boozy raisins
[Music]
a fantastic tip for leftover lemons and
limes is to cut them into wedges freeze
and use them like ice cubes they won't
water down your drink and they'll also
add flavor
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips 100 recipes to stay your life
on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking
welcome to my ultimate cookery course
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stake your life on right
now it's all about stress-free cooking
cooking dishes in advance is a brilliant
way of taking the stress out of cooking
at home and many dishes just get better
and better with time
first up my amazing sticky pork ribs one
of the secrets to great cooking is
patience leaving dishes to marinade for
one or two days helps to develop the
flavor in your food and
the end result so much more delicious
it's a method i use in the restaurants
all the time
first off get your roasting tray put the
tray on the gas
pork ribs 60
meat and 35 40 fat give them a really
good season salt
and pepper
nice thing about this cut they stay
incredibly moist when they're on the
bone and the longer you cook them the
more delicious they become and just push
all that seasoning in to the pork
olive oil in
make sure that tray's nice and hot
and i really want that nice sort of
caramelization taking place on the pork
that's the nice thing about starting it
on top of the stove use your roasting
tray get them colored and then the oven
putting the ribs straight in the oven
you don't get the color it looks sort of
boiled as opposed to a nice caramelized
rib
ginger
you can't beat fresh ginger with sticky
pork ribs
place it down nice and firmly and slice
the thinner you slice the ginger
the more fragrant the ribs
garlic
now it's really important before you add
anything to those ribs make sure we've
got the color from the ribs first don't
rush it
turn them over
that's what i want
that nice crispy color
as they sort of
braise in the oven all that color just
turns into the most amazing flavor
braising is just a chef's turn for
cooking something slowly in liquid
right ginger and garlic in
spread it around on all those ribs to
sort of roast the ginger and the garlic
chili flakes
chili flakes in next szechuan pepper
citrusy vibrant peppercorns incredible
in
next staranese that gives it a really
nice sort of aniseedy flavor almost like
you're roasting the ribs in fennel and
now we've got the heat
got the spice
i want to sweeten things up a little bit
some fresh honey
honey glazes the pork beautifully
counteracts against all that spice in
there
but look what's happening a colour on
the ribs is extraordinary
it's like a really nice chili
sweet caramel now
soy sauce brings that little bit of sort
of saltiness to it
really generous with the soy sauce
japanese vinegar
two tablespoons of vinegar in
rice wine
it gives it that nice sort of um
tartness the ribs
if you can't find rice wine our dry
sherry's a great substitute
300 ml
that takes out the heat of that szechuan
pepper those dry chili flakes make sure
they all lay down like a nice tight box
of matches bring that up to the boil
cooking is all about learning to develop
your own likes and dislikes so always
keep tasting to make sure you're happy
with the combination of flavors
it's lacking a little touch of vinegar
all that sharpness now think what's
going on the tartness the heat the
caramel the color on the ribs is amazing
i want a bit of a sort of oniony flavor
put some springiness in
whilst these ribs are in the oven the
spring onions will sort of puree but
give a sharpness
the final taste of that pork
in with my spring onions
and with my stock
400 ml of stock
this is just a
simple chicken stock
the stock just sits underneath the ribs
it absorbs into the rib and the top of
the rib glazes
underneath the rib that gets crispy and
rich and that's what makes the ribs nice
and moist
really important into the oven
cook at 180 for 30 minutes
then turn the ribs over and cook for a
further 30 minutes
now
wow
they smell incredible
each side has got that really nice
crispy roasted edge becomes sticky and
chewy and sweet sour the fats
disappeared and the pork just melts in
your mouth i want to take them to the
next level gas back on now
shake the tray
and this is the sort of
the way that we finish them in the
restaurant
every minute
they glaze
in that tray they just get to taste
better and better
now look at them
i'm so happy with those
ribs done absolutely delicious now but
if you want you can put them in the
fridge and the flavor will keep
developing then just reheat them when
you want to serve
so
[Music]
each rib has a nice slice of ginger on
there
[Music]
wow look at that
delicious sticky ribs
with an amazing marinade
to make my food the tastiest it can be i
always start with the best ingredients i
can find
and the secret to getting the best is
simple
knowledge is crucial the more you know
about where your ingredients come from
and how they produce the better so ask
lots of questions and learn
when it comes to buying pork you can't
do any better than ask a butcher and
award-winning master butcher danny
lidgate knows everything about the pig
from trotter to tail
his family have been in the meat
business for 150 years so this man
really is on the money
in comparison with other meats pork's
really good value you get some really
good cuts at really reasonable prices
and you can use everything from the tip
of the trotter down to the cheek we can
see here we've got the leg the leg is
about this region
really lean really good for things like
gammons and hams
coming down from the leg we've got the
loin and that's where the pork chops
come from if you take the bones out you
can bone and roll it and you end up with
a really nice easy to cook cylinder of
meat really easy to carve carve like a
loaf of bread
coming away from the loin we've got the
belly
and you can see what belly is made up of
fatty parts and meaty parts don't be
scared of the amount of fat that's on it
you need that fat to give give the
flavors coming through
also make sure you can possibly buy it
with the skin on the skin will crispen
up nice and give you good crackling also
add flavor into the fat
lower down from the bellies we've got
the shoulders
really the shoulders are a great meat
they're slightly fattier than the rest
of the animal you can see with this pork
shoulder the amount of marbling you get
in the muscles the interior marbling
make sure you look for the marbling it's
essential for the flavor and it's going
to make a really good eating experience
with a pig there really is nothing to
waste the trotters even are really good
flavor because they're geletinous
qualities and the meat can be really
really flavoursome also there's pigs
cheeks which obviously require a little
bit more cooking because of the use they
get but the flavors you're gonna get are
gonna be completely different to any
other part of a pig
pork is an incredibly versatile meat
they say the only part you can't eat is
the oink
here's my guide to getting the best out
of familiar cuts
smoked or unsmoked bacon is not just for
breakfast it's brilliant transforming
salads gives a real depth of flavor to
stews and is delicious in quick and easy
pasta dishes
[Music]
the leg joint best known for ham also
makes an inexpensive delicious sunday
roast and it's great served with peas
pudding
and the tenderloin fillet incredibly
lean healthy and fast to cook you can
stuff it cut it into scallops or strips
that are perfect for asian stir fries
[Music]
a calm kitchen is an efficient and
effective kitchen the less stressed you
are the better the food you'll produce
so whenever you can get ahead with your
cooking
here are three of my favorite recipes
that can be made beforehand and whose
flavour improves over time
[Music]
first up moroccan lamb with sweet potato
and raisin
[Music]
this super simple hassle-free recipe is
cooked all in one pot start by browning
chunks of lamb in hot olive oil
colour and remove
then fried onions
season
add chopped garlic
ground ginger and coriander
a teaspoon of whole cumin seeds
paprika and fennel seeds
a cinnamon stick bay leaf
and delicate strands of saffron
then fry to release all the aromatic
flavors
next add tomato puree
chunks of sweet potato and the juicy
brown lamb
for a sweet note add plump raisins
then cover with stock and simply leave
to simmer for a couple of hours
delicious eating straight away but over
time the flavors will develop and
improve
when you're ready to serve simply finish
with fresh parsley
[Music]
minimal preparation and ready when you
want it fantastic moroccan lamb with
sweet potato and raisin
my next super simple dish that just gets
better and better with thyme is chili
chicken with ginger and coriander
[Music]
start by chopping chicken thighs into
pieces
now on with the marinade
chopped garlic
ginger
red chili
lemon juice
[Music]
in a pan toast coriander and cumin seeds
to release their flavors grind and add
to the chicken
[Music]
then pour over plain yogurt
add turmeric and season
mix and leave to marinate from two hours
to overnight
next fry chopped onions in olive oil
then add chopped garlic and ginger
ground coriander garam masala
and turmeric
tomato puree and butter
next add the marinade chicken and all
the remaining marinade and cook until
tender
finally topped with coriander
marinated for flavor and cooked in 20
minutes chilli chicken with ginger and
coriander a simple stress-free wonder
having a delicious sauce on hand to
serve with simply cooked fish or meat is
a brilliant stress buster my final
recipe is sweet pepper sauce with
grilled prawns
[Music]
for the sauce in hot olive oil
fry chopped garlic and diced bread
[Music]
then put them in a blender
[Music]
add chopped tomatoes
[Music]
blister the skin of red peppers under a
hot grill intensifying the flavor
leave to cool then they're easy to peel
chop and add
blitz
add smoked paprika chili flakes and
roughly chopped almonds
a squeeze of lemon and a dash of sherry
vinegar
season
blitz again and add olive oil
[Music]
this sauce keeps really well in the
fridge and will intensify in flavor
i love it with simple king prawns
just add olive oil
and griddle for two minutes on each side
[Music]
sweet pepper sauce with grilled prawns
simply delicious
[Music]
made in advance ready when you want them
three stunning simple recipes that take
the stress out of the kitchen
beautiful this is my ultimate cookery
course 100 recipes to stake your life on
i'll be showing you an amazing spicy
chutney that's brilliant for
transforming the simplest of suppers
they don't actually smell much but the
flavor they give off is extraordinary
but first five more of my 100 tips to
make your home cooking easier
kicking off with how to skin and de-bone
a fish the hassle-free way
this is basically a filleted side of
salmon it's been taken off the bone and
now skin off
pick up your knife a really nice broad
flexible
filleting knife
a little sharpen
lift up
the base of the towel and then just nick
a little bit at the end there twist the
knife almost as if it's horizontally
underneath the salmon pull
the skin and you slice
the salmon underneath and let the knife
do the work now get your skin
flip it back over
and check
you're not leaving too much salmon on
top of the skin
pull it back
nice and slowly get the skin wrap it
around your fingers pull the salmon
towards you and then just all the way
through
lay that down
one
nicely skinned salmon just like a
perfect snakeskin
get your knife and just run the knife
down
and then
with a pair of tweezers these are fish
tweezers but you can use normal tweezers
look for the head
up
and pull
and with the skin being removed from
underneath the salmon
the pin bones come out a lot easier
and the pimples only go to just
basically halfway
along the fillet
one nice
fillet
of salmon
beautiful
[Music]
there's still plenty of flavor in the
trimmings from affiliated fish my tip is
don't waste those fish bones add to
water why a bay leaf and some chopped
veg to make a simple but versatile fish
talk at home the perfect base for a
delicious fish soup
[Music]
a great tip for intensely flavored
stress-free veg is to steam them in
their own juices simply add to a pan
with a knob of butter and seasoning then
cook on a low heat with a lid on to lock
in the moisture
[Music]
for crispy roast potatoes you can depend
on my tip is to par boil them leave them
to steam dry then sprinkle them with
semolina or flour and give them a good
roughing up this ensures they go really
crispy in the oven
a great tip for browning meat or fish is
to dry it with kitchen roll before you
cook it then you'll get a much better
color too much moisture makes the meat
steam instead of sear and you'll lose
that rich brown crust like the one i got
on those sticky pork ribs
another secret to taking the stress out
of cooking is to anticipate the really
busy times when you'll need things to
hand that are already made
my next recipe can be kept on tap in the
fridge for weeks on end and is
guaranteed to liven up any quick meal
spicy chutney
with chutney standing by in the fridge
you can always add that special little
touch to a simple supper prove that
thinking ahead always pays off
pan on start toasting those spices keep
the pan nice and low cumin
very aromatic very fragrant and it's
almost like a light spice
next nice little coriander seeds
coriander in now you're going to get a
bit of heat in the chutney mustard seeds
well smaller than coriander seeds but so
much more powerful mustard seeds in
now
curry leaves
they don't actually smell much dry
but the flavor they give off is
extraordinary coli's in
really important not to burn them
otherwise you'll
have that bitter taste
across the chutney keep the gas nice and
low the secret is sort of toasting them
so it releases that oil and intensifies
the spice a touch of salt
and then a couple of small powerful
chilies keep them whole
no one's going to eat them but it gives
that real nice burst of heat
now let them toast gently there we're
not going to chop the onion we're going
to grate it
why
because it sort of breaks down to a
really nice puree in the chutney when
you're grated hold the root in the palm
of your hand
and just push
nice long
grates
want those nice long shards
look i've almost got a nice sort of
onion puree but it's nice and clear
a touch of olive oil
spices nicely toasted onions in
[Music]
three nice cloves of garlic slightly
crushed on
[Music]
lay it nice and flat and just slice the
garlic
nice thin slices
garlic in
taking your time to get the owners
caramelised beautifully will really reap
rewards in the long run
tamarind paste and sugar in with the
sugar first three nice tablespoons of
sugar
that will give a really nice syrup
effect
sort of nice rich syrupy texture
to the chutney
tamarind paste
you can get tamarind paste in most delis
and the big supermarkets
it's really nice thickening asian but
gives that tartness the chutney and it's
sort of rich sugary spicy
next in with my coconut add four nice
tablespoons that will give a nice body
and a really nice texture to the chutney
cook that coconut out and now add the
carrot
grated
the carrot just gives the chutney really
nice sort of crunch but also helps to
sort of cool down the spice
carrots in
the water comes out the carrot flavors
the chutney beautifully but gives that
nice sort of vibrant bright color to it
as well
and grating it almost sort of it cooks
instantly but i want a bit of texture
through here
turn down the gas and just let that
simmer for five minutes
if the carrots aren't that moist and
juicy then put a couple of tablespoons
of water in there to help it along
now
just cook that out
for five minutes
just as those carrots start going nice
and soft don't overcook them you want
that nice texture in there slightly
spicy slightly sweet
gas off
keep those chillies in there for that
it's beautiful
nice and gooey delicious and
ready to go in this jar as that sits in
the fridge
just gets better and better and better
i love to eat this chutney with
cold meats or even cold fish but with
ham it's amazing
it's a really nice way of living up the
ham
just sort of roll it up
get a nice spoon of chutney i mean it
looks fantastic
chutney onto the plate
and serve and that is a
nice little
gem in the fridge that is worth prepping
in advance for
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips 100 recipes to stay your life
on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking
you